[Music]
you talk about charles asking camilla
what he thinks the complexion right of
the baby will be right harry and megan
during the oprah winfrey interview said
that they had learned that a royal had
made kind of a racially charged comment
about skin tone
concerns and conversations about how
dark his skin might be when he's born
what
i was able to trace back though to a
comet that was made by charles to
camilla over breakfast the day their
engagement was announced it was innocent
benign there was nothing negative even
if it was innocent it does not mean that
it wasn't racial there's no question
that megan and harry are right as harry
put it shocking and awkward but i don't
think it was convenal in in the racist
in the way that was then made out to be
just hours after this claim made
headlines the palace issued a denial
saying charles never had this
conversation calling the claims quote
fiction they are the emperors of denial
i have rock solid sources that verified
this is what happened you stand by i
absolutely stand by everything in the
book
in brothers and wives out tomorrow
anderson also claims one final blow that
led to mexit was when the queen removed
harry and megan's photo from her 2019
christmas speech
another bombshell the author says
william was once so depressed kate and
harry staged an intervention for him
there was a big crisis when william was
flying an air ambulance helicopter in
northern england he was coming you know
seeing death uh in the most horrible
ways william said i felt at a certain
point the death was around every corner
that's how dark got he was in this this
downward spiral of depression kate was
getting very very worried and she
enlisted harry in convincing william to
get help
as for the deep rift between william and
harry right now it looks like they're
done with each other but you know we'll
have to wait and see i mean it's a toss
up
[Music]